ladies and gentlemen welcome to the
podcast uh
now we did decide on 8 45. now there was
a little bit of a there was a time
change
but what do you mean there was a time
changer we asked to come a little
earlier last minute but not really last
minute it was yesterday late afternoon
and you specifically said charles
are you confirmed for this yeah and
charles said
yes okay
interesting
i didn't see his i i'll admit i did not
actually look at his response i assume
that when meg said we're on for 845 that
she had had confirmation from him uh i
just said did we get confirmation from
charles and charles said yep i'm good
well i will say i was a little confused
the other day because i popped in and
late yeah a little bit late i was
well
uh so call time was 9 00
am and i thought like oh everybody shows
up we don't usually use the terms call
time it's more just like hey let's do
the podcast yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
my bad i think cause because you know
mara well well well there he is what's
up cool is coming in hollywood cool guy
what's up hollywood
i'm gonna keep my shades off look
maximum awesome
well you do look
okay
hollywood charlie hey man you know you
said 845 and i knew it was gonna be a
tight squeeze from me because the the
nanny was getting in the house at 8 30.
i knew it was going to be tight mm-hmm
to to make it here in 15 minutes from my
house but 15. 15.
but i was like i could either
do another five texts being like i might
be five or i could just be like let's
just see if it happens and if i'm five
late it'll be good fodder for the pod
yeah because there's a lot of textbooks
you texted yup i'm good yeah well yeah
it was yesterday yeah yesterday at 4 30
yeah yeah yep i'm good and guess what
you're good hey i'm good [ __ ]
you're great
hey you're one of the best hey man you
were the best you guys
let's get it going
[Music]
i felt nothing but love for you guys
watching this episode i'll tell you what
uh i i i love this i'm like
so i forgot i almost forgot to watch it
and i i had already like put my son to
bed and he was actually sleeping in our
bedroom
because he's having some problems with
like nightmares and and so i was like oh
i can't i can't leave because he doesn't
want us to because he keeps waking up
and he needs somebody there so i was
like so i just watched it on my phone in
bed last night and had to like seriously
stifle a lot of like laughter so that i
wouldn't wouldn't wake him up
uh i i just loved it i had a lot of out
loud laughter as well for this
particular episode yeah yeah now anybody
who's watching along with us will will
notice that both danny and caitlin are
not in the episode right mm-hmm and if
you guys remember the reasons why
no um i think that
they couldn't be there danny couldn't
yeah well
pretty
this was not something that we
that we engineered we did we didn't
write the episode thinking oh it'd be
great to do an episode without them it
was that they came to us and said um
um much like you had disrespect for our
time today uh they had disrespect for
our shooting period and they said yes
you know those like
month and a half period
are you seriously
going to
uh no
no i'm going to roast caitlyn and danny
for a second you know that month and a
half period where you guys just you know
you you ask us to show up and say the
words that you write that we've been
writing for three months yeah yeah yeah
and that you'll edit into the show and
and then we get the rest of the year off
we just we can't make it that way we're
not gonna be able to make it just
character why what was it well danny
needed two two episodes off actually
because he's not in the
uh the whatever the bark critic one
that's coming up he wasn't in that one
and i don't remember what and i but i
don't remember why and i don't remember
why caitlyn needed an episode i do
believe it was injury related that's
what i thought with kaitlyn it was
something to do with
when she broke her back but how would we
have known that yeah in order to write
it because we presumably it was written
ahead of time right
oh no it was rewritten oh we rewrote oh
yeah that was like one of the la the way
so she didn't rewrite that episode maybe
it was the time that she broke her foot
well when did she because she broke her
foot this this season
was that season three that was season
three season three she broke her back
season four she broke her foot okay yeah
and so she really truly couldn't walk
yeah and and we worked around it for
some episodes in other episodes it was
we just couldn't do it yeah but why
now they got paid just to be clear it's
america they got paid for that
yeah
yeah yeah
i want to get paid for work i don't do
god bless yeah god bless
i know um they got paid for the episode
uh they have to you know pay her play
pair plays you know but we were like hey
they're the ones who say they can't yeah
they can't play right you're telling me
you can't play anymore
[Laughter]
yeah pair plays when we don't want you
to play and we have to pay you because
we chose yeah we said you can't play and
you're like well i get paid to play you
know i'm fine you'll get your pay which
won't get you play
but if you come to the game and say i
can't play
i won't find well here's the pay anyway
then you know that's that's
tough i mean like in uh professional
sports if you're injured they don't they
don't take away your uh your salary
right
yeah workman's comp there right right uh
but but i danny i feel like he was
prepping he was a movie yeah the movie
that didn't go and it didn't it didn't
come or
morgan freeman something he was
directing yeah and he's gonna direct it
and he needed morgan freeman and he had
to like go to mississippi to like visit
with morgan who i think lives there i
could be making that up but
um it's from there uh anyway he had to
go somewhere to like
sit with morgan or it was like a i
remember being in the trailer down by
those stages in culver city and getting
a phone call
saying i need i can can you work this
out i need to go and fly and see morgan
and we did because you know what we're
great partners well i tell you what i
think the episode and this is not a yeah
there's a high five happening oh
listeners
really that was bad so sad
of a best friend
let me go with my right hand
oh
damn nice good okay
that was somewhat painful for the people
who were still listening they finally
connected on the high five yeah
and for the creeps maybe we can do like
a that first one was absolutely you know
what it is it's coming from the side
here you gotta go
but i still i couldn't get enough whip
out speaking of high fives can we just
talk for a second about caitlyn's high
five
that's what i was trying to emulate
there she's got a wicked one where she's
sleeping so katelyn's skateboarding she
puts a little pop in it doesn't she
any time like i'll go to give her a high
five yeah you hold your hand you're
getting ready to go for it and she just
whacks your hand like that's how and
then and i would talk to her about it
and be like that's not how you high five
she's like yeah it is you you yeah you
slap the person she puts an extra pop in
it yeah like a cobra like that's
striking yeah yeah she yeah
the way she was pecking at that sandwich
yeah so caitlyn and danny were not in
this episode it was just the it was just
three boys and and the waitress um
really fun oh man
uh you know
it's so
it's interesting too right like so you
have this contract you have these five
actors and you're like okay we have to
write for them in every single episode
and let's figure out how to represent
everybody but
i don't know something pops up then you
can't use two of them and you're like
okay we have to figure out something
else
and
it's something we haven't done because
that's just not the way the sort of
contracts break down but like from a
creative standpoint yeah yeah it's great
to just focus on these three and their
relationship for this one episode i'm
surprised we haven't done we've done a
little bit more of it as the years went
on and we'll do more episodes that are
have more heavily focused on a couple of
characters or one character yeah you
know where the other characters just
kind of come in and out yes it's just
fun to keep it fresh and keep people on
the toes yeah it's such a fun episode
like the just the exploring the dynamic
between these three characters like just
you know the concept of three men in
there in their early thirties like
arguing about
which one of you is like who's who's
best friends in [ __ ] this is the
simplicity of the scenes is super
refreshing like
i come over to your to your apartment
and that that's one of my all-time
favorite scenes in the in the entire
series is when you come over with the 24
pack of beer
and that whole sequence from from
getting to the house to the end of the
night
peeing in the bed
am i peeing
what are you peeing oh this is peeing i
told him he was going to do it i knew he
was going to do it he drank too much
goddamn hey guys if i'm peeing wake me
up
yeah it's some of my favorite stuff yeah
you're right that that entire that
entire sequence i mean that scene where
i'm desperately trying to get you to
sleep in my room and trying to engage
you in some sort of fun activity you
know it's watching a dvd but i remember
i remember us
like a lot of that
i think actually that entire board game
conversation was improvised was it yeah
it feels i think in the script it was
just it was just like we could play some
board games you're like man i'm not
really into that or whatever and we
looked at the board games that we had i
think in the they're on the set like i
think there were some board games on the
set and we were like let's just chinese
checkers
yeah
connect four that's a lot of counting a
lot of counts really but not really
you know one two three four yeah but
over and over and over again yeah but
then there's so many times you have to
do it how many times you have to do it
how many times you get one two on the
game
like yeah i i have to admit i feel like
i'm stealing some
some moves from jason bateman in that
scene i was watching that today that's
what i felt like i was like oh this is a
this is very bateman yes uh and i i
think that uh it wasn't intentional
initially but it was like as i was doing
it i i could feel it coming up you know
what i mean is like i i just i've i've
always admired jason bateman he really
mastered the dry straight man and so
anytime you want to go dry it's hard not
to be like oh i'm slipping into a
pavement i could i couldn't help it in
that moment it just felt right um but i
will i will fully admit it and give him
credit for sort of the the rhythm the
inflection
sort of like the way i played that scene
with you you know and it's fun because
those are colors that i feel like i
don't get to play that often on the show
like especially in the later seasons as
my character gets more insane more more
art angry more nice to see like a little
wand a little needy a little needy yeah
yeah yeah um these scenes are played
very
natural i mean i guess except for like
some super drunk acting but like but
even that i mean yeah it's all kind of
really grounded and
and intimate which is so funny to me
well it's an emotional episode it's
about it's about well on the surface
it's about love and about wanting to to
to demonstrate that we we are actually
the ones who love each other more yeah
but really it's it's a desperate need
for
pursue we back it up to the how it
begins with a little project badass sure
um
is that mark skeezak on the bike or is
that is this before mark's this is
actually this was one year before mark
skis oh really that wasn't skeeza no it
looks like him and i've asked him mark
skeezak is our uh stunt coordinator uh
on the show and has been for many many
years and is the only person who's ever
been nominated for an emmy yes yes in
the show multiple times yeah and
deservedly so yeah um
but uh yeah i thought that was mark on
the bmx it looks exactly
so that was all born out of our love for
jackass
yeah right how much we love jackass yeah
that was our version of jackass right
yes and found out that knoxville was a
fan of the show and and we were trying
to find ways in which we could
incorporate him right
that and i think it was the next season
that we tried and yeah we had a whole
script we had a whole thing yeah oh yeah
the guy like we were trying to do a
jackass thing
and then something happened where like
one of those guys like oh no that's what
it was one of them came into the bar and
they were like super depressed yeah
right and they were just drinking and we
were like oh [ __ ] that's the guy from
jackass like we should do some stuff
with him and we kept trying to like
jackass prank him oh right and he was
like [ __ ] just getting irritated
and then i think like somebody ends up
in
somebody ended up in jail we should pull
out that old script yeah let's bust it
out
it is interesting how the week before
and this week it does have a
or at least the way into the episode has
a lot to do with these sort of
you know social phenomenons of the time
whether it was reality shows or jackass
or things that
felt fresh i don't know what would be
today you know like i think
is anything new
no not for not for not for us not for
for me i've i've sort of enclosed myself
into a little bubble and um
and nothing sticking with the classics
i'm just sticking with the classics yeah
and uh and i feel it i feel myself i
feel the world passing you're done
that's why we do film noir episodes now
that's right yeah exactly right right
yeah yeah yeah um but no but this is
this is something that you've talked
about many times that and i think
something we all love is like the
relationship episodes you know those are
some of the guys there's just always
some of the best ones where where it's
really just about
relationships and about like the
you know the needs that you have and the
the the you know the inter the what's
the what's the word i'm looking for the
um interpersonal sounding no uh
interstellar this is this is that by the
way this is happening to me now enter in
my fortress i'm losing
intergalactic
no no um uh uh
oh my god did you say tito's antenna
yeah tito santana intercontinental
champion wwf
six to 1989. positive that those are the
words you were looking for yeah yeah
they weren't uh but you know fair enough
um
you know when you're when you're santana
was it
when you have an unhealthy relationship
with somebody you're oh oh uh
dysfunctional dependent oh co-dependent
that's the word i was looking for
codependency yes surprised
a lot of codependency at play the um
the scene where you were you know you're
on the walkie-talkie for the first time
first of all just a stat like
that is the kind of thing that like when
when you were kids like walkie talk you
got some walkie-talkies and you were
like holy [ __ ]
whoa this is so [ __ ] cool we can i
can talk your qb like over there and i
can be over here and we can talk to each
other and like i wonder if we can reach
all the way to our houses and like like
and the fact that these men in their 30s
are are still like obsessing over that
but there's still something i find
exciting about a walkie-talkie
yeah even though i have a thing in my
pocket where i can look at your face if
you are in egypt
and talk to you in real time
but if i have a little like
walkie-talkie yeah if i pick up a signal
of someone else somewhere i'm like well
that's really exciting i'll tell you
what
i remember i remember
when you end that first or when he
abruptly ends that first walkie-talkie
conversation and i'm just kind of
hanging there and i'm like
he's lying
he's spinning you a web of lies charlie
the head
but you committed to it yes because once
your the arms and the hands go up you
can't you can't no that's the that's the
stance you took and you know that was
the big reveal that's the reveal my
friend looks over and i'm doing the
thing it's like and i remember thinking
like as we were shooting that i'm like
this is a little too high
and then i was like oh that's actually
funnier yeah yeah yeah it's funnier than
that it's an awkward stance yeah
the don johnson reference
is classic that's a good run we've had
two don johnson references on the show
do you know the second one
yes
i don't was it in the
uh was it more recently
was it in the haircut was it in the uh
it's a little bit of trick because we
don't actually say don johnson but we
are referring to don johnson
sonny crockett what a
nash bridges reference
it's a lyric and
uh the gang turns black
i miss my old camaro and my mansion in
van nuys yeah still wish i hung with
nath nash bridges and those and played
poker with the fall guy
he poker with the fall guy yeah man yeah
he misses he misses hanging out with don
johnson and lee majors
yeah sat next to don johnson once at a
dinner party
at rob blows house
and don johnson was a very cool
i loved it it was a very cool i always
loved don johnson speaking of um mixing
it up a little bit with people not
in the episode
you'll notice that there's an empty
chair over there
now now megan's still getting paid
but she's not playing we'll see about
that but yeah yeah maybe we should
should be talking about that she'll talk
so we could fit yeah we could carve one
out yeah
well because she's not playing and she's
not pay to play pay or play
i don't think we signed anything that
says pay or play no no we've not okay
yeah but she's gonna be editing the
episode so if you don't play there's we
have a choice
she's still gonna be doing some playing
she will be and in fact she said she set
this whole thing up and then she sent us
a bunch of questions and things so she
is playing i suppose yeah she's also
going to be involved in the editing of
this yeah that's what i said
oh you're not playing either because
you're listening i don't know i'm only
halfway here you're here but you're not
playing
well let's see let's see what if we got
some some fun questions here that uh meg
prepared
uh were you now were you guys fans of
jackass actually when it came out yeah
i was too i was blown away the
television series before before yeah i
loved it you know it's crazy i do i'm
sure yeah
i'm sure i watched the tv series
i don't know that i've seen any of the
movies oh god they're fantastic
they're fantastic i don't know how i
have it they are genuinely genuinely i'm
sure yeah yeah i think it is i will say
though it's the kind of thing that's
like best experienced in the theater
you know with a giant group of people
the joy of uh yeah and i can't remember
watching a man set his balls on fire in
a group yes exactly
yeah i i don't know i may have talked
about this on the podcast before but i
took jill on our very first date
together i took her to
sushi
and then we went and saw jackass too
and the fact that she was down
to do that and excited to do it and then
you know enjoyed the movie just as much
as i did i was like
yeah yeah this is this is the one this
is the one did you have sex that night
we didn't
i feel like that's like what howard
stern would ask and uh how was the sex
right you know yeah not that i want to
be howard's turn we uh
we did not we did not we we actually
didn't have sex for a little while we
waited till i got married well she
waited i think should she didn't she
she was maybe not sure no well there was
a period i remember where you were like
uh this i like this woman but i know
this is well the real story is uh we
started dating and she
was like six months out of a
six-year relationship
so she was like
just not
uh ready to be in a relationship and i
could tell and she pretty much told me
as much and i had been single for like
three years
and
you know
wasn't like trying to get in a
relationship but when i met her i was
like oh this isn't the kind of girl that
i just want to date like i this is like
serious girlfriend possibly marrying
material and she just wasn't ready for
that so we dated for like
i don't know three weeks and then i
actually called it off because
i was like i don't want to just date you
and this feels weird and i feel like
it's you know like we're we're just like
it was a dynamic that wasn't quite
working and i was like this is a good
move this is a howerton special you saw
that she was going to do it first
and you said no
you said no you knew you saw the writing
on the wall and you were like this woman
is great she's gonna tell me to [ __ ] off
what i'm gonna do is i'm gonna tell her
to [ __ ] off first well yes but it was
also you know
i did i was aware
i was aware in the back of my head that
like i was doing something arguably sort
of impressive
walking away
walking away from a relationship dressed
by this break system well because of my
random system because my reason for
breaking up with her was that i liked
her too much
and that she wasn't ready for what i had
to offer we got to get a board up here
and get the glenn system up i want to
know the action but what was her
reaction to that well i will marry you
and have your baby yeah yeah no it's no
at first it's oh okay but then weeks go
by she's like what she's like this
creep's trying to clean me she's running
he's trying to clean me but i somehow
i'm into it what would the glenn system
be yeah g
gloat
[Laughter]
gloat first go to woman i think go go go
go go go go for it go for it go for it
love making it lift off yeah love making
love making go for it love making
escalate escalate
that's like a classic neglect what is
that weird like pickup artist [ __ ] um
what do they call it oh negan
oh nagging negging next so that was your
that your first then is the neg so you
took it all the way then you neg you
negged her egg and then nuptials neg and
then nuptials
that was the glenn system yeah wow just
the one time just the one time did you
ever think that maybe you were caught in
a web of her making
i'm sure i don't think look because
she's smarter she's definitely smarter
than you and that she could the second
she locked eyes with you she knows she's
like this guy's trying to break up with
me and do the whole thing okay sure
mm-hmm
yeah but she'll have her on we should
have the the
we should have jill on
right because we've had your wives on
now when we get to that makes more sense
when we get to that when we get to the
dentist system episode we'll have jill
on and she can tell her version of the
story
yeah and we can cut all this
and we can cut all this because it'll be
way better with her it'll be fresh and
new with her there i don't know i i find
it fascinating it is fascinating yeah
it's interesting i i'll see what else i
feel i find fascinating and this is why
it went into the episode um
within uh there's a very
i i think a very popular subset of of
pornography viewers who really enjoy a
close-up of genitalia just smacking
together i've never understood this
i think it's the actual pornographer who
enjoys it and clearly doesn't know it's
all they're watching it i don't think so
i think it's a way to um
stitch scenes together
yeah it's a cut point yeah so you need
something to cut to what about
what if all we can see is his [ __ ]
and his balls you're going to make a
porn and you're like oh you know what
i'd like them to be at least a minute
and a half long and uh this this one
lasts about 35 seconds um so i'll
i'll go to the library of ball and
vagina and uh you can pull it out and
slice that in and i'll lengthen up this
episode yeah it's just like it's crazy
dehumanizing right is that the idea that
you're just you're
you're decapitating the people you're
you're suggesting that they are not
humans i think who who who is attracted
to that
no i think it's you're getting a closer
look at what's happening you know you're
like
you're like i'm really engaged in the
story but what's really happening in
this story i apologize to everybody out
there who is into that and there's
nothing wrong with it yeah there's
nothing wrong with that i'm not sex
shaming anybody don't close up [ __ ]
scenario
fascinating uh it is fascinating i i i
can tell you that i'm not into it
that's not what i want to see
you know i feel like charlie's defending
it he might be into it which is fine
again can you walk us through why you
know can i just tell you what i'm
waiting i'm not into it i'm just trying
to figure out why it's in there and i
think it has to do with the storytelling
you know i think it really has narrative
bring the audience closer to the story
that you're trying to tell you know
you're trying to get people to be like
okay these two people are having sex but
how is it happening you know like what
what
is what are the steps it could be or it
could just be their version of
like what is the speed at which this is
happening you know like um you know like
i know i can't smell it but i imagine
the closer
the closer a view i get the more i could
sense well you get to see who's
generating the power you do who's
generating the power who's receiving the
power who's receiving and who's
generating yeah you do get a little bit
of that
i don't know it's definitely it's
definitely for the male audience right
am i am i is i think it's all for the
male audience
i think sadly you don't want to finish
your porn and feel like i didn't get
enough coverage you know what i mean
like
you know you don't want the editing
we don't have enough angles here and
this is no one's gonna watch this well
and also like you know you're trying to
get you're trying to appeal to everybody
you know which is why you know
somebody's at some point often
somebody's gonna do something with a
foot
you know and then you're gonna get a
shot of the guy's you know butthole
cause you know who knows who's watching
who knows who's watching and who's into
what you want to give them a little bit
of you're trying to get those vhs's to
fly off the shelf right and uh you want
to make sure the
everyone all the creators are yeah
all the creeps are satisfied
[Music]
well guys if you haven't heard the news
yet
it is smooth sack summer say you're a
group of fighter pilots right you don't
say that okay and you're playing and
you're playing your balls in the sun
whether it's volleyball or it's or it's
some weird sort of two football but
either way you've got expert ball
handling skills and you want to impress
the ladies or each other or each other
or actually more so each other and then
you want to make sure that those balls
are aerodynamic right uh hydrodynamic
and smooth to the touch you want the
leader in below the belt grooming what
do you want you want manscaped the
manscape performance package 4.0 has
everything you need to prepare for that
glistening dewy
inexplicably sweaty just very overall
damp
summerbot yeah now about that lawn mower
it features a ceramic blade with
state-of-the-art advanced skin safe
technology to reduce grooming accidents
now i cannot tell you how thankful i am
that they've developed this safeguard
against what can be extremely painful or
somewhat embarrassing he says from
personal experience
yeah it's smooth sack summer guys not
scarred sac summer get 20 off plus free
shipping with the code
sunny
manscaped.com that's 20 off plus free
shipping with the code sunny at
manscape.com it's smooth sack summer
boys get on board or get left behind
sunny at manscape.com
hey what's up creeps glenn here
[Music]
sorry about that cut that cut that got
that um
let's go again um
okay what's up creeps glenn here sunny
merch is now available
[Music]
okay
hey guys
i'm wearing a sweatshirt with my face on
it and you can too
at the merchandise store wear a
sweatshirt with my face on it not yours
what are you a narcissist
go to the alwayssunnypod.com
merch and get you some podcast merch
baby
is this the first episode where we
established that you have a camera
running in your
bedroom at all times yeah yeah
yeah that's really disturbing i remember
doing it and be like hi is it too far
but it's funny the drawer full of tape
the drawer full of tapes and the wood
starts your reaction number one
the number of different number of
different waitresses is always coffee
shop yeah there's yeah there's like
waitresses you're disappointed that it's
a one-star tape
well she's disappointed yeah well you're
in you're no you say it's not good it's
not good that's not good yeah yeah yeah
but see it's episodes like this and
situations like that that i i don't know
i mean we don't need to get into this
again but go ahead when we talk we're
going to start talking about
episodes that are pulled or banned
for for very specific yeah why is that i
look at this and i say this one should
be better if if you're looking at the
show and saying we're taking this all at
face value yeah that intention doesn't
matter that essentially the subject
uh the the the subject that we're
addressing
is should be taken at face value and
that these characters are presenting
them
as human beings who we're and and whose
lives we're following um and there's no
satirical element to it then there's a
there's a case to be made that certainly
an episode like this should be pulled i
mean it's like such an insane violation
that dennis is perpetrating we go on to
suggest also that he's potentially
a serial killer like a legit
mass murderer oh oh later yeah later
yeah yeah yeah in the series again if
you're taking it at face value are we
suggesting that this is something funny
this is something to laugh about same
character is harassing a woman for the
entirety of the series he's lovable but
what he's doing is yeah entirely
inappropriate
yes
yes
uh it's funny it is funny it because it
is despicable and and
despicable behavior is funny it always
has been it always has been and again
we're not saying these are good people
so it's not you know
but uh yeah anyway so
let me see if we have any other uh
we have any other prompts here uh
okay actually this is a good one
charlie your character drinks by the way
you're drunk acting in this episode
is just
fantastic oh thank you i love it
how about you shake your mind off of it
with some pizza
and some beer
oh
that's right i ate all the pizza
a nice drink on beer you must be wasted
dude 24 beers by yourself and i'm very
wasted
i love it so much i love the i love the
i love the weird little body choices
that you make like when you're drunk
like that you it's almost like you don't
have as good of control over your limbs
it's always fun to do right because you
feel like you have like a
i don't know you have like a pass to
just go as far as you want right like
because you're drunk so you're like i
don't know try anything try this posture
try the speech pattern well you've
always been good about i will say you've
always been more brave and so far as
like you're willing to just really go
for it like make a really bold choice
and that was something that took me a
while to kind of get to a place where i
felt
comfortable doing that like it's a good
thing because
you're good enough actor to where it
doesn't you you can go big and it's
still
there's still like a
a kernel of truth to it kind to you to
say and i'll take all the compliments
but 24 beers is a lot how many beers
have you guys ever had in a single
sitting or not in a single sitting but
here's the thing about over the course
of a day
when you get past 10 you are losing
count you know sure
and if there were periods a long time
ago where yeah you would start a day
drinking
episode with friends right in your
barbecue early 20s
and it would start i remember uh there
was there were some bars on the upper
west side of manhattan
and on saturday mornings they would run
a
they would run a a promotion where you
paid 40
and you from 10 a.m
until 4 p.m
you had all the beer you could drink and
all the wings you could eat and they
would just put college football on wow
and you would go
you would go there and you we would
spend from 10 to 4 there and you just
stumble out of that place probably yeah
but we would transition straight from
that into another like party and then
another
bar after that sure and so i don't know
i mean the wings in this and the celery
and you're drinking probably some kind
of light beer because you gotta you
gotta pace yourself to a certain sure
extent yeah you're not drinking ipas
you're not drinking 24. no no no no i
but but i have to assume there was 30
beers drank
from the time you i started at 10 a.m so
you think you think you may have you
know i don't have
any other alcohol i'd be surprised i bet
i
i bet you're capping out before 24
before a full case yeah
in in a in a 10 hour period from from 10
a.m till what are we talking like
midnight an average of two beers an hour
two two beers internet two beers in an
hour i think you start to slow down
after a while probably probably slow
down to one beer an hour at a certain
point i think you're gonna probably
the brakes are going to start coming on
depending on your body weight and height
and all that
by time you get near 18.
and they probably should
yeah i probably should i don't think
i've ever had anywhere close to 18 beers
in a day i i just don't i i can't i
don't think i could do that i don't i
think um i couldn't at 45 but i
could at 25. yeah over the course of
like 10 hours yeah 10 hours maybe right
yeah because
after 10 you really don't know what what
you're doing well
sometimes it's
easy to count right because you you you
bought two six packs right and then
you know one of them's gone and then you
know half of the next or something like
that so you can it's easy to count
you're passing them around yeah you're
carrying them around yourself and not
letting anybody happen
oh there's other people there yeah
oh i was just alone watching a movie in
my house you're drinking so long
sure no that's what that's what it turns
into that's what it developed that's
what you become and that's your later
20s and your early 30s and yeah yeah
you're still you're still doing it
uh
24's yeah um 24.
let's see
dead air dead air
[Music]
i don't know guys
let's just hear him anyway okay
and then let's ridicule megan for
writing
yeah
you know it's meg you're not here and
yet you're still doing work
yeah
and we we got nothing
we came ill prepared we watched the
episode this episode is rated in the top
10 percent of all sunny episodes on
who's rating that i'm db
people i put it up there
but but but how do they just imdb folks
so top rated episode of people who go on
to imdb to vote about episodes i guess i
don't yeah i don't know i don't know but
i'd put it up there
i'd put it way up there because i i
think because like and i've never really
thought about like what are
[Music]
i think it's because there's there's
like three or four scenes in this
episode that to me are like
scenes that i point to as some of the
funniest things the scene the scene
where where you know you come in to give
me my walkie-talkie and admit to me that
you've been banging the waitress
and we you know and you explain that
we're we're we're closer than best
friends we're blood brothers
and he's asleep and then he wakes up and
you hide under the covers right at my
crotch
what am i seeing yeah and you come over
yeah when you go i just remember like
shooting that and thinking this is
this is so like the way you performed it
too yeah this is matt schackman director
in this episode yeah
what what is it that
you know you look at our show and the
coverage the
coverage of the camera angles uh
coverage uh for i guess anyone who might
not know is like when you're looking at
a porn and suddenly there's a very
close-up shot of
the genitalia moving it
aggressively
speeds um
that's a piece of coverage um but like
like the coverage of our show is very
simple we don't have dollies we're not
switching lenses on the cameras it's not
but something that matt shackman does
it makes these episodes
work so i think i don't know what it is
but the
maybe it was the writing maybe it's all
that together but
he really has many many many many
good episodes
and
when he's he's also uh you know somebody
that can direct
in so many different genres like the
fact that he went from sunny to mad men
to game of thrones yeah i know well you
know
it wasn't a very eloquent question but
i'm just wondering what he does with how
he covers these episodes
that makes them feel very natural and
very
where another episode might feel a
little more clunky yeah
and i bet
he's a bigger piece of the puzzle than
obviously give him credit you know
well i g yeah i mean i think i think
we give matt a lot i'm like i i
certainly i mean i think that some i i
love working with matt i wish we could
get him back but he's too he's got too
much corn he's got too much going on
he's got too much going on
he's doing way cooler things but there
were whole seasons of sunny that he he
directed every episode
he dropped an entire season did he do
all season five
he did the whole season
all ten twelve i think we got twelve
that year because i think you can make a
strong argument season five is our best
season
parts of this season as well i think
season five is one of my one of my
favorite seasons for sure yeah yeah and
a lot yeah and shakman was had a huge
hand in that while also running a
theater company yeah amazing
amazing amazing you guys wanted to try
something different what do you want to
try i had an idea just in the moment
here because just because i'd like to
see it and i'm going to pretend like i'm
an audience member who appreciates your
comedy i don't know i think i would love
to see this because when we shoot this
episode did we establish like
13 years ago uh
2008 2008 so yeah 15 years wow no 14 14
i would love to see
if you guys just on memory and having
just seen the episode
could recreate
write for us right now recreate the
scene in which
you come in with the beers
and you
are trying to get him to sleep in your
bed
like actually try to remember the words
well and then come up and then improv
your own words as
recognizing what the scenario hey yeah
we could try it you can always cut it
yeah you can always cut it and i
think it could be really funny i think
you shouldn't be here
because is that going to throw you oh
i'm a mess well the reality of the scene
is you're not sitting here the reality
is
i've come over to hang out with you
mm-hmm and you're not here yet and i
have to talk to you that's great okay so
we're gonna do almost like a theater
like a theater look at these like linen
pants well man these are great i meant
to bring this up the whole outfit's
really good i said it sure headed
straight to the caribbean after this i
meant to bring this up when we were
talking about don johnson when i was
watching the don johnson i thought and i
have this like some linen clothing yeah
i was going to give my best don johnson
look all right
what if i sat over one minute and then i
can just i can observe yeah you're the
audience i'm the audience this is the
set audience is over there all right so
because we said we'll set the scene then
um i'm coming over and i'm sleeping over
mac and i want to get
over there but you're here i'm trying to
get you over there okay yeah yeah yeah
okay great all right we're gonna give it
a whirl all right i hope this is i hope
this is okay for the listeners yeah i
need my beard
oh
oh yeah it feels very out of character
i'm a different character yeah well me
too i mean now you need your hair i need
my hair golden god hair
they put on my like
a hairpiece now do you want me to say
action or should i just stay out of it i
i think action is i don't know you want
an action it it does something to me
okay
right you know what i mean like
are you going to start with a knock what
does what does the scene start with no
you just you just come right in yeah
sure okay now glenn is dennis reynolds
here
yeah sadly always charlie charlie kale
here yep here we go
and
act hey
what's up buddy how you doing
hey
i'm glad you made it i grabbed that
sleeping bag from you oh yeah no that's
okay because um yeah i'm just gonna
uh oh you in your room yeah i'm glad you
came over man i just i'm gonna pop this
in my room and then uh you know we get
that set up then we can forget about
that and move on to whatever else no
that's i actually think i was going to
sleep in mac's room so
oh well i mean there's
you know a lot more room in my head yeah
it's not small i made a plan already so
yeah but
okay you know i feel bad if i wasn't in
his room when he
got back here
okay all right
that's good
um we'll toss it we'll toss that in his
room and then we'll okay we'll get into
it uh see well yeah i mean i don't know
if all if like we should be like in a
thing you know when
matt gets back because it was gonna
happen i i think it's i think it's
probably fine i know she got 24 beers
there so crack some of those up get
crack crack some of those open and get a
little tipsy kind of for me and mac oh
really
um okay well that's 24 beers yeah you're
gonna 12 for me you're really going to
drink all that 12 for mac 12 12 for you
and 12 for mac yeah so that's kind of
our thing really that's a lot
not that much just half a case it's a
hell of a lot uh we could probably
divide those up eight eight eight
and make that work but uh you wanna
drink them you wanna drink them all
that's fine i think that's i got some in
the fridge why don't we do something
else we wanna drink them all let's let's
let's uh let's do something man what do
you want to do hey you know what we got
i got a bunch of new board games i got
the oh i got the classics too we got we
got chinese checkers you can do chinese
chicken foreign to me really
play a foreign game
you know okay
well we got uh we got clue we could
solve a mess mystery together yeah it's
a little too mysterious you know
and feels dangerous with all the weapons
and stuff okay so you feel like
something might happen
i just want to get like poked or
anything like that yeah you wanna okay
well let's find something less pokey
let's uh
get back in get back here sorry you're
the browns you're sitting there giggling
all right
you know what's around is we could do
some connect four oh a little those
little round guys yeah but you can get
your finger caught you know if you put
it in there and you can like lose your
whole finger i can tell you how to avoid
that i can tell you how to avoid that
yeah it's not i mean it's not really
that sharp it's not like a guillotine
you know yeah so i could because i
really got my finger in there because
because that yeah it's a lot of
countertops
my whole night counting well
it's not that much counting one two
three four and then you win
yeah but over
yeah but over and over and over again
man i'm gonna spend the whole time
counting
you know yeah you just do it once you
know one two three four and game's over
you've won
yeah but
i mean if i'm gonna spend the whole time
counting and playing with pokey things
it's like not really what i came over
here to do you know like
kind of just want to get and what about
just got a bunch of new dvds uh like
you know some sequels that maybe you
haven't seen yeah but maybe i haven't
seen the first one
well i probably got the first one too if
i've got the
dvds i've probably got the first one too
if i have the second one i've got the
first one yeah i don't know so we can
sift through those and find like the
first one you don't even know
wait get through that get there
that would be the bit so what would
happen is we would be like oh
that's that's what the scene's about and
then we would laugh through the first
take of it yeah okay okay now now make
sure that's one thing maybe the whole
thing about the movie i mean he doesn't
like that he doesn't even know what they
are
got it yeah but i okay
really like the first one you know
because the first one was kind of scary
okay we we haven't established what
movie we're talking about here well you
know most of them
most of the first of movies that have
sequels are scary to you well you know
there's always like you never know when
something's gonna be like there's gonna
be like a bang or like uh-huh
[Laughter]
yeah and you get you get startled easy
that's fine we can do we could do a
combination we've got three amigos when
was the last time
here my eyes are
there's too many amigos
that's an odd number odd number amigos
now we're back to counting so
[Music]
well you guys are my amigos i really
enjoyed um this episode i enjoyed this
podcast i enjoyed watching you work
and um
yeah you know and uh quick prayer yeah
and uh
okay all for one and one for all yeah
right that's the
huh
right what's that oh yeah yeah
and then you
burst your crotch out uh can you name
the three writers of the three amigos i
can there are three
writers
credited for writing that movie do you
know who they are rob macquarie
lorne michaels
sorry well i didn't know it was joe
sorry
uh chevy chase that
well are they either do they premiere or
do they appear in the movie
one does can i get a clue
who are they steve martin
yeah steve martin lorne michaels
and there's a third party is it
is it the director
don't tell me don't tell me don't tell
me is it like a is it a is it a big name
that you wouldn't think yes is it joel
cohen or ethan cohen is that one of the
things it's a big name you wouldn't
think cause he's not known for writing
uh screenplays
something else i know who it is oh my
god i know who it is known for writing
something else
um
it is a songwriter that charlie the
character charlie often emulates
that charlie that charlie day also
really likes i'll give you another clue
this whole episode is about friendship
and uh you know you have a friend in me
oh
oh um
uh i love l.a um
i'm blanking on his name
um please don't tell me
uh randy newman randy newman yeah
michaels
and uh steve martin what a crew yes
weird right mm-hmm yeah interesting uh
you wonder though how much
yeah like what was that what was the
because i mean it's not really i mean i
think it was they wrote it on the season
that he wasn't
running snl there was the
oh he stepped back first he stepped back
for like a year or was it two years like
a year
and they all got together and they kind
of kicked around this idea and they they
wrote uh holds up oh yeah it holds up i
mean i haven't seen it in probably 10
years but the last time i saw it i i was
laughing a lot more than i was expecting
to laugh it was a lot of good luck
i love that marty short yeah same love
that marty short man he's a genius
and there's one joke in there where he
goes yes
uh see that that male plane up there um
and goes how do you know it's a male
plane
tiny little balls
i don't get the balls balls
yeah and that's the little wheels but
like uh oh oh okay but uh you know
male 1 yeah yeah no i got that yeah yeah
well the the funny part is i think it's
steve martin who goes through a series
of like laughing
and then not getting it and like getting
it for a second and not getting it
that's the best part of that joke well
how do we end on a high note i try
[Music]